is she using the leaf to blot her tears
it would be weird to give her tissue
Mira we make children's books maybe it's
better to prepare them life will
inevitably Crush their hopes and dreams
[Music]
you know I'm just wearing my dead
boyfriend's shirt and texting his whole
number
Rob wanted to make sure you got one of
these I have a phone you have a personal
phone this is a work phone
I miss you so much there's a making
inside of me
do you have a question for me yes Miss
Dion do you really believe in all these
things you sing you obviously know
nothing about it what
[Music]
uh it's been two years since you passed
and I still can't believe it who is
sending me these texts every morning I
open my eyes hoping I'll still see you I
must have the dead boyfriend's number
that's super sad I think they're nice
there is nothing wrong with putting
yourself back out there again you're
going there get the D you make it sound
like I have a vitamin deficiency yeah
you kind of do you have a vitamin D
deficiency because when the sun comes up
maybe we just take it a little slower go
they're never gonna hold me down I think
I might have feelings for someone I've
never met these things you're receiving
are saying something it might be crazy
but love doesn't always follow the rules
[Music]
I'm wearing it to the Opera tonight
these are from a literal stranger I just
need to put a face to these texts
[Music]
I know you I'm not sure oh my God you
just got yourself a date the normal way
she thinks I am interesting you need to
tell her the truth you should have said
something to her right away
you'll never speak to me again
I was looking forward to this I just
felt like I knew you or something do you
think you could fall in love with
someone just through their words
you're very cute
the more I get to know her the better I
like her
[Music]
looks like this
don't happen love is a plan for each and
every one of us
hi this is silly Dion sure and I'm
Mariah Carey love comes to those who
believe it and this is really me oh my
gosh hi
[Music]